make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
marvel's god mutant is coming back and i
am so excited man the matrices okay so
here's
here is here's sci spurrier man so sly
spirit is the one doing way of x
normally i would do these in order right
i would do way of x number one and then
i would do way of x number two
but the fact that i'm doing this out of
order should show you anything that i'm
super excited so marvel's god mutant is
coming back and initially this comic
opens up with legion that's hint number
one
it's not legion legion's super powerful
legion's amazing and i love this i love
like the power okay those of you guys
who are unfamiliar with legion
legion has essentially an infinite
number of personalities and each
personality
has a power now they don't all have
different powers that's an important
thing that i do want to make a
distinction of they don't have different
powers right like you have whole bunches
of personalities that can manipulate
fire you have whole bunches of
personalities like the origamist that
can manipulate reality on different
levels you do have really cool
personalities like susan and sunshine i
love susan and sunshine
she's like she's like the cutest of the
personalities but also like the most
horrifying at the same time because she
can just screw with you so
bad but nonetheless uh it's one of these
cool things right so the way this picks
up
is you essentially have legion attacking
nightcrawler
one of the things to know legion is
probably just one of these really
socially awkward people right like
legion doesn't know how to convey his
emotions it's really the way legion
works right david is a little wonky here
a lot of it's because he's just so
socially repressed
and so because of that him attacking
nightcrawler it does serve
a particular purpose and the reason why
is because he's looking to investigate
the mind of nightcrawler
and he's looking to understand
nightcrawler's mind because what he
wants to know is whether or not
nightcrawler is a person who can be
trusted now when he does enter his mind
it's actually
really cool so initially legion thought
it was going to be like and he even says
it's like this is not what i was
expecting right he thought it was going
to be all churchy right like stained
glass and
pews and altars and all that kind of
stuff which makes sense because most of
you guys who have been reading
comics long enough know that
nightcrawler's devoutly religious
but one of the cool things is that
religion never really governed his life
right he didn't live and die
by his religious convictions he kind of
has done done things in the past that
are
not really in line with religion as you
traditionally see it and he'll do the
same thing in this comic too right but
what you end up getting here is like
this old age of like storms and like
like ships on the sea
rides like pirates and so on and so
forth so essentially like the 1800s and
it's amazing and it like this these
ships or at least this one particular
ship
is being manned by all these different
versions of nightcrawler now
something to know here is that legion
found something
in the mind of nightcrawler and we won't
really find out what it is until much
later on right but it is going to be a
super cool thing
the big thing that legion has here is a
kind of artifact that he extracted from
nightcrawler and again we'll talk
more about that here in a minute but
it's one of these things where this
basically confirms what it is that
legion was looking for
and that nightcrawler can be trusted
here right so he's like okay i put
coordinates in your brain meet me in
that location in ten minutes and find
some people you can trust right so he
immediately beelines back to gracoa and
we end up coming across dr nemesis
and fabian cortez now fabian cortez i'm
not gonna lie
he's probably as unimportant as anybody
could be here on the island of gracoa
but there was a time
when uh when fabian cortez was amazing
and i've actually got you know i still
need to give those away the comics from
x-men volume 2. i want to keep like the
first four or five for myself right
because those are like when omega red
first showed up different things like
that but fabian cortez was a character
who appeared in marvel comics and he has
the power to boost the abilities of
other people there was a point when he
first showed up at marvel
he was basically a kind of religious
zealot in the sense that he saw magneto
as like the lord and savior of the human
race if you guys ever watched x-men the
animated series and you remember that uh
that episode was a two-part episode
sanctuary where you have like fabian
cortez and those guys the acolytes right
that's a pretty accurate depiction
of fabian cortez at least personality
wise anyway not all the actions that he
engaged in were accurate but in terms of
personality that's pretty accurate here
uh but again this is just one of those
instances and i kind of like that marvel
does this it's one of these instances
where you just kind of have this person
who was at one point
a major foe of the x-men who's just kind
of on krakowa right because it's one of
the things for those of you guys who are
kind of picking up on on the x-men at
the moment kind of let me sidetrack for
a second for all of you guys who've been
reading it for a long time those of you
guys who are just kind of joining us the
idea behind krakowa is it's basically a
mutant nation and so it's one of these
places where when xavier and magneto and
maura mctaggart founded it it was kind
of like this idea of
all past transgressions are kind of
forgiven but not really right but at the
end of the day there's no like
us as mutants and you as mutants there's
no more factions right there's simply
just
us as the mutant population it was a
complete and total coming together of
the mutant race on a singular island
those guys who were like really big
dicks right like apocalypse or something
like that they were a little wary like
some people were a little wary of them
but it's one of these things where it's
just kind of like a safe haven right so
everybody kind of puts past
indiscretions and they all just kind of
unite under a single banner right now
doctor nemesis
is exceedingly important here and this
really in a lot of ways comes out of the
story
age of x now i don't know how many of
you guys ever ever uh read that story
and if you didn't make sure you guys
check the description one of the things
that we're doing now is we're linking
like all the parts or really like the
the whole playlist for a series down in
the description so you guys can get
caught up with the most recent episodes
or stories if you want to but dr nemesis
is a person that has a lot of dealings
with
legion and he really understands as best
he can anyway the ins and outs of
legion's mind and so if ever you were
going to take anybody with you to quite
literally navigate the mind of legion
dr nemesis is the one to do it but one
of the big things that you you kind of
have here is my crawler just pops out of
nowhere right and it's like okay
uh so i need some people to come with me
right so he ultimately ends up snatching
up pixie who basically is a character
that has magical powers and actually was
at one point kind of a fun little fact
here she was known or she was at one
point
in line to be considered to become the
sorcerer supreme instead of stephen
strange but it's one of these things
because of the magical power she
possesses marvel's kind of hit at over
the years that pixie would be
stupidly powerful if she was ever truly
trained in the mystic arts by steven
strange right she would rival even him
in terms of her magical ability which in
this day and age is not overly
impressive
back in the 60s and 70s was insane but
it was it was it would be kind of nuts
and so ultimately they end up arriving
in the rubalkali desert in saudi arabia
and so when they get there of course
they meet with
david holler and so one of the things
that happens is they basically enter
into the mind of
david and kind of find out exactly
what's going on here right that in
essence
his personalities have run awry now the
best depiction of legion's personalities
really came an x-men legacy right the
old x-men legacy story in the the early
to mid-2000s really the mid to late
2000s uh and what you kind of got here
is that with legions different
personalities who were here
because they are all essentially
autonomous they can think on their own
they have their own wants and desires
and things like that
that it can really cause an absolute
mess in the mind of legion if they all
just sort of run amok like they're doing
here and so what normally happens is
legion kind of has them in well i guess
really prison cells is the best way to
describe it and whenever he needs to use
the powers of one of his personalities
he basically
siphons off the power of that
personality uses it and then gives the
power back to them when he's done but
it's almost like flipping through and
grabbing cards right is really kind of
how that works the biggest issue that
you have here is that if you
look at something like the old x-men
legacy stories where you had the
quote-unquote prison break in legion's
mind
and all of his personalities were
basically taking turns kind of using the
body of of legion that's sort of what's
happening here now
the big difference is that a lot of this
seems to have been engineered
by orcas and in fact you have like
nightcrawler and pixie who are going
through and facing off against all these
personalities
as best they can now one of the big
things that kind of goes on here and
it's sort of intriguing is that legion
cannot actually fight against his own
personalities and this kind of comes by
way of an explanation in terms of how
all this happened in the first place
that what seems to have happened here is
that the organization orcas
introduced the only you know it's really
just kind of described as an invasive
exotic right to kind of speed up the
collapse of legion's mind
uh and essentially it's almost like
introducing a virus or
foreign entity in his own mind that
keeps them from stabilizing all these
personalities
and keeping them safely locked up in
essence and it's really the best way
that legion describes it the inmates are
running the asylum
and there's no way for him to corral
them all back in and the reason why
is because some of these beings out
there some of the personalities he has
are actually more powerful than legion
in his normal form he's super powerful
right he's an ultra high end like beyond
omega level
uh telepath and telekinetic but then
you've got people like the origamis
right who can alter reality
even inside of his own mind so it's very
difficult for
legion to be able to pull this off and
so ultimately because of the fact that
this kind of
system is expanding the way that it is
because the mind is quite literally
falling apart and going into a state of
degeneracy basically meaning legion's
mind is destroying itself which is
really what all these different
personalities kind of represent the
chaos that's going on inside his own
brain that you end up having the only
real option that's there
the only option that's really given to
us is that legion's gonna have to die
now again
because of the fact that hickman
established that superheroes can
essentially be resurrected this is what
this is the kind of thing we were
talking about here right and that's why
when house of x and powers of x first
launched and jonathan hickman was just
like we're basically killing off the
idea of death a lot of people kind of
rolled their eyes and they were like oh
my god really but it's a really great
thing here because
instead of using death is like a shock
value thing like oh my god this
character died
and you knew they were going to come
back so their death had no real
significance
instead they're using their death as
significance not in so far as the fact
that they're gone and they're never
going to come back but using as a method
of storytelling and this is one of those
perfect examples that one of the most
powerful mutants in the world who has an
infinite number of personalities and
each personality having a power has lost
control of all those personalities and
and by default
lost control of his mind and so it's
only a matter of time before he
quite literally becomes a power bomb in
the sense that like when he goes off
all of creation will go with it right
like at the very least the world will go
with it but seemingly the whole universe
would go with it and so the only thing
to do here is to kill him so that he can
basically be reborn on krakowa
with all this madness kind of back in
stability again because remember
whenever they resurrect people in
krakowa they essentially use a quote
unquote backed up version of their mind
so it's like when you restore your
computer from a backup
and seemingly the backup they have for
legion is a backup that exists before
orcas did all this stuff and mess with
his head and so what ends up happening
here
is you kind of get again this
questionable moment with nightcrawler
where essentially
instead of allowing dr nemesis to do it
because it more or less falls in the
line of murder that you end up having
nightcrawler who's like i will do it
instead because at the very least he can
do it from a place of selflessness and
do it from a place of religious
conviction and so what this kind of
means is that his soul quote unquote
wouldn't necessarily be tainted but this
is one of those questionable things
because even nightcrawler says like he
tells legion you are not your flaws
david holler and if destroying a lump of
empty meat will help you to start afresh
to rule yourself well perhaps there are
sins worth sinning and so it's not as
though
nightcrawler approaches this from the
perspective of like father bless me for
what it is that i'm about to do or
father forgive me for what it is that
i'm about to do his soul is cleansed
from executing legion it's not really
coming from that perspective it's hey
look like
sometimes we just have to do things that
we don't want to do because it's what's
best for everybody else and so
ultimately he essentially pulls the
trigger and just just basically kills
legion's mind right like just
like shoots legion's mind on the spot
that's kind of the crazy thing is
because
david holler as you've seen him here
this entire time is not physically david
holler right it's just kind of his mind
essence
and that's why he was showing up in a
kind of astral form because it's just
him more or less leaving his physical
body right but it's one of these crazy
things because everything that's gone on
here and what orcis did
by screwing with legion's mind that all
leads to something big
and this big thing gets revealed when
you basically have legion who's
resurrected through the protocols right
and so of course like once he comes back
it's a pretty big to-do right there's a
lot going on here like there's a lot of
excitement and a lot of curiosity
because a lot of people are just kind of
like i mean
it's a little wild because one of the
things that's kind of hit on here
is that there's this almost sense of
unease that permeates everybody in
krakowa this kind of
feeling that something's coming that's
going to cause all kinds of hell right
like something's coming this is that's
going to
turn everything they know and love
completely and totally upside down and
so once david holler is restored of
course he chooses to continue going by
the name legion and then one of the
things he establishes here is he doesn't
trust charles xavier as father
and he doesn't trust magneto he doesn't
really trust either of them but he does
trust nightcrawler and the reason why is
because he says okay
like i'm gonna borrow you know
nightcrawler for a minute and
i'm just gonna go have a conversation
together and as the two of them are
talking get this really really
interesting thing
where they start talking about what it
was that legion found in the head of uh
of nightcrawler and when he says like
like do you remember that thing that i
found and i was like yes right that kind
of poisonous coin and that's where
nightcrawlers like it's you know
if i'm being honest it sounds like
whatever orcas did to you
they're already doing to us here right
like they somehow found a way to infect
us
already and so in essence this this viru
this virus right this kind of rampancy
that's going on in our heads
it's only a matter of time before it
fully manifests and it scares the heck
out of me this is what's so cool is
because
what was going on there and something
that was kind of haunting nightcrawler
and this idea that legion had hit on
that he had like all these questions
that he wasn't really vocalizing that
nightcrawler asked legion
do you know who the patchwork man is and
the response of legion is
yes i do i can send some kurt clear as
day and there's a good reason i didn't
say so
to dad or magneto that's your second
hint xavier
and magneto in what instance have we
ever heard of this ridiculously powerful
force
that basically has to do with xavier and
magneto legion says
parents don't always think straight when
it comes to their heirs but he says this
thing this patchwork man
it's onslaught curt onslaught's coming
back onslaught's coming back
osha oscar's coming back summit on slot
is coming and i'm so excited with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you